so in this session I'm gonna tell you
about two things the second thing is a
proposal that I'm making to improve
Python into the future it is at five
five one on bringing security
transparency to pilot the first thing
I'm going to tell you about is why
that's important and why you need it and
the reason you need it is so I did some
research I before this talk I did my
research I went into your company and I
had a look at your network security and
you should you should recognize this
because this is your network security
everything in here are the bad guys and
this little section down here are the
ones who are successful who here has
ever received a spam email with an
attachment those are all the guys in the
top who he has I'm sure no one here has
who here has a colleague who has open
one of those attachments all right now
now those are the guys at the bottom but
being a successful bad guy doesn't
actually mean that you've lost and so in
the rest of this I'm going to go through
why that's a big deal how we can deal
with it and how my proposal was going to
help Python help you deal with them so
first let's take a look at some of the
vulnerabilities that you are going to be
facing this is an example of exploiting
a buffer overflow in an old version of
Python this has been fixed so if you're
up today then it's not going to work but
I want to show an actual example because
a lot of people haven't seen what
exploiting a buffer overflow looks like
even though we know that they're really
bad security vulnerabilities in this
case this is the content of a packet
that you can send to a Python server and
if it's using the receive from function
that's going to overflow the buffer let
me take the padding out of this and you
can see there's some X values in there
those would actually be encoded their
addresses of various things and the
padding is there to make sure you
override the right parts of the stack so
the stack in C for those not familiar
with it has more than just local
variables it's got various addresses
pointers if you override it
you can change what the program is going
to do next
change the return location from a
function that's what this last value is
the one starting with e that is the
address for this particular target
system of the system function and then
the bit that comes after it is the
argument we're going to pass to it we're
going to execute bash this is a proof of
concept real more realistically have
some sort of command like this which is
going to go off and grab some arbitrary
code from the internet and run it with
tighten on your machine how do you
prevent people getting into your systems
through these kind of vulnerabilities
the ends up patch all the things all the
time many of the recent exploits you've
heard the reason why so many of you have
credit freezes right now because various
people did not patch everything all the
time someone found out that a
vulnerability existed and they used it
to get into that system but even if
you've patched everything even if all of
your software is as up-to-date as it
possibly can
there is a bigger scarier class of
vulnerabilities than buffer overruns
what quiz which one of these is fake Oh
better yet which one of these do you not
want to actually type your password into
it there is a correct answer and it is
possible to tell who says the one on the
left is fake who says the one on the
right is fake the answer is the one on
the right you can tell it's fake because
the batteries are a hundred percent well
you can also tell by a few little things
that some interactive methods so it's
not completely foolproof how many of you
have a colleague who would see this pop
up and enter their password into it it's
the entire room it turns out that even
easier than finding a buffer overrun in
some on software and carefully
constructing a packet with addresses two
functions of the particular version of
jlmc that's on that machine and filling
in the arguments to execute arbitrary
code on that machine it's easier just to
ask the user what their password is and
most of them will give it to you there's
a Python hacking tool
at their code fella that will detect
iTunes pawza pop up a dialogue saying
you need to enter your password to get
iTunes back and then it just saves the
password and unpause as iTunes this is
ridiculously successful and very easy
what's the fix for this okay that got
about the reaction I expected cuz you
know users learn they're all very
interested in sacrificing their ability
to get worked on in order to protect
your network security make sure that
nobody's getting in shouldn't be never
take work home never log into personal
debate yeah okay that's not gonna work
we can try this this would work no more
users no one to give out passwords no
one's getting it what getting done no
more income no more need for submit okay
as soon as people are involved attackers
are going to get in that's always gonna
be it there's always going to be someone
possibly a recruiter a recruiter is
always gonna open an email that says I
really really really want to work in
some dark office at your bank dock space
space space space space space space
ducky exit so your network security is
always going to look like this which
brings in a concept that has been around
in network security for a while but is
really solidifying as something that we
can talk about it's called ashume breach
and this is a mindset to defending your
network that says people are going to
get in the only people who are not going
to get into your network other people
who don't care about you and even then
people still want to get into your
computers so they can use them as
botnets distributed denial-of-service
against other people who they do care
about and they just got into yours
because it was easy assume breach says
that people are already in what do we do
now let me illustrate this with a few
series of animated graphics we have bad
guys in the world somewhere and they're
trying to get your
Bank of valuable data emails Social
Security numbers
employee and for whatever that happens
to be ideally for them they're just
gonna go straight in and take it that
doesn't work because they don't have
access because you keep all that stuff
private however you have computers on
your network that do have access to that
and if the attackers can get into that
computer then they can get into the
crown jewels or you have multiple
computers that can get into each other
and if the attackers can get into any
one of those computers they can get from
there into the next computer and
eventually find one that has access and
go get whatever they like but it gets
worse because you've got employees and
so this device is on your network that
you don't think of there because someone
has brought that phone in connected to
Wi-Fi and you don't know what else
they've brought in they've brought a
laptop in connected to Wi-Fi you don't
know what they've brought they've got
work on but it gets even worse do you
know about every single router on your
network you know what versions of
firmware it's using you know under
abilities it had your attackers do it
you know about all the network princes
on your now on your network your
attackers do every network connected
projector network connected coffee
machine light bulb thermostat the point
of assumed breach is that your attack is
a far more patient than you and they
know your network better than you ever
will I have literally seen maps the
researchers have gone out to networks is
administrators and say draw me a map of
your complete network and they come back
with you know one hundred two hundred
computers with lines drawn between them
and it's great and then they go to the
penetration testers who have attacked
that network and say give us your map of
this network and there's a thousand
loads on it with ten times as many lines
between everything as a system in slope
they actually had you can't control
everything on your network you can't
prevent anyone getting in what do you do
next an attack looks like three pots
versus infiltrate we just talked about
that they go to
get it you'll do the best you can to
protect against attackers getting in
assume breach says assume that you will
fail eventually what do you do next
the next thing an attacker is going to
do is try to persist they want to keep
code in your network they want to stay
in your network and so what you do in
that case is you want to detect them
their aim is to get in hide and stay
there and these days we're seeing what
are called advanced persistent threats
where they stay there for years without
taking anything without causing any
damage just sitting inside your network
replicating from machine to machine
completely undetected and able to do
whatever they want whenever they want
because they persistence so well and you
haven't detected and finally they're
gonna try and export rate they're gonna
take your data and get it out again
without you noticing and people don't
notice attackers have exfiltrated
gigabytes to terabytes of data from
companies and companies don't notice
because they hide it as part of normal
traffic but you have to respond once
you've detected an attacker in your
network let's track them down shut them
down it's get them out the assistance is
the interesting one because this is
where we want to detect them when an
attacker is looking to persist their
malware in your network they're looking
for a range of things that it can do
they really want to execute long
compiled code this is anything that can
be run in memory this is a state machine
that given some data they can execute
this is a Python file that they can just
exact or eval they don't want any
validation most machines or most
operating systems have the ability to
whitelist binary code or add extra
validation code signing to rule out
certain pieces of code that aren't
trusted from running attackers what I
avoid that because they can't
necessarily sign their code with
something with your machine with trust
they want to be able to write files so
that they can persist change settings
access the network to spread from
machine to machine create servers
because when it comes time to interact
with it someone's going to want to log
that machine and if they can spin up any
kind of interactive server then they
want to be able to do that and they
don't want any login that's how you get
found some examples of tools that you're
likely to find on your network that can
do this bash
pretty good for this depends how complex
a program you want to ride in it our
shell is very good very popular except
in more recent versions of PowerShell
we've invested heavily in security and
so this is not such a good option
because a lot of the proposal for patent
I'm going to present has already been
done for power shop so you can heavily
restrict what code it's allowed to run
where it can come from and log
everything so that if PowerShell is used
for anything you know exactly what it
was useful well again if you really want
and of course the reason we get talking
Python is an ideal tool it fits all of
these characteristics and it's by design
Python is designed to do all of these
things which makes it really hard and so
the response from a lot of SIS admin's
is to simply remove them from the
systems if you go for a minimal server
image you're going to avoid as many of
those tools as you possibly can because
of the ways they can be misused again
this is right up there with banner you
uses it prevents you from actually
getting work done so the middle ground
instead of banning it it's to order them
it's to know what they're doing
continuously be collecting as much
insight as you can into what they're
doing who caused who caused them to do
it what they're accessing and just know
at all times
what all of these tools are doing so
that you can make the determination is
this a good thing is this a bad thing
this is security transparency this is
being able to see into your systems all
of your systems and have a good
understanding of whether they are being
used for good purposes or evil purposes
so at five five one is a proposal to
introduce features into Python that will
help it be more so
transparent the aim is to take this
statement that people have said - is
banned on this network and change it so
that they can say python is okay because
it's audited because we know what python
is doing we can tell the difference
between when it's doing good and when
it's doing that we don't have to just
outright ban it as a developer who works
in Python you don't want Python to be
banned because you want to be able to
write production code in it you want all
the benefits of being able to work in
Python which means you need to get the
system administrators on site so they're
willing to let you do that and not take
a stand in the name of security and say
you cannot use Python on these
production machines who knows what this
does exactly the number of people who
I've shown these slides to perform so
this is one line of Python code that is
executing arbitrary code this is the
kind of thing that an attacker is going
to throw at your Python on your machine
to get initial access this is just a big
blob of basic C foreign credit text
asking about base64 encoding it's gonna
take multiple lines of code and render
it as one line of aluminium we can
import base64 under coda and then
execute in a valid which lets us do any
number of things and in this case if we
run it again - - see so I don't have to
have a file on the machine all I need to
do is that earlier vulnerability with
the buffer overflow - let me run one
single command and I can get way the
Arne if you want to try to solve all of
the code is in that geography I didn't
expect anyone to take a photo of this
slide and copy it out but feel free
security transparency and the books that
at five five one composers are meant to
answer these questions what code is
actually running who's looking at that
command line if that's all you're gonna
see in your normal log you have no idea
what it's doing
what files or network access occurs
where where is it getting its
information from where is it quitting
new information where is it storing
itself where is it replicating - and
what red flags are there because a lot
of code does this all of your code is
going to access files access network and
it's going to run a whole lot of code so
you need the red flags to be able to say
this should not be happening there is
something weird going on we need to
investigate this is a sample of the log
file that my reference implementation of
this pep comes up with its heavily
abbreviated you say there's a few lines
there that say imports X number of other
modules that one bit of code actually
imports over 100 modules so simply if
you've wondered why Python starts
absolutely it imports a lot of stock at
startup but simply having a lot of
modules being imported doesn't give you
any red flags there are some red flags
in here though
because it's very rare that you're going
to have deployed production code that's
been code reviewed checked into github
or checked into whatever see I run
through CI tested published or deployed
that is evaluating from a string anytime
you see compiling a string object that's
probably a red flag and you'll see in
the first case is actually the code that
was hidden inside that base64 string
because whenever we hit an eval or an
exec we've got to go off and compile a
strength so in this case the log has
just dropped out exactly what that code
is that was hidden behind that big water
character and then the later one down
the bottom is a second set of code
that's being run we can see in between
network access there are hooks that take
every URL open call every socket that's
created every address that's resolved
and just Thompson it's all it's doing
it's just providing the ability to
access that information as it happens in
this case we've put it in a log but it
means we can now see where it's where
it's getting it started from
and this is a very important point about
this proposal at 5:01 does not
automatically make - more secure because
with the reference implementation of
this pep actually nothing changes in a
normal installer file what has changed
is there are now hooks there if you're
listening to those books you get more
information by default python does not
listen to those hooks because it can't
do anything with the information it can
make a huge huge log file but most
defenders don't actually want a huge
huge huge log file because they have a
security system if you're serious enough
about defending your system to be
interested in this you already have
logging setup because your operating
system will log many of these events for
other things your operating system is
going to log every process it gets
started it's going to log potentially
files that are accessed in various
places or everywhere it's going to log
network connections in certain ways if
you're not paying attention to that this
proposal doesn't help you because you'll
continue to not pay attention to the
extra information if it will help you
you have a system to integrate it into
and so that's your responsibility yep
yes on at the next slide or the two
slides but the integrity of your system
is your job or someone you pay to care
about making sure that everything
interoperates properly but if you have
system day integration order the
integration if you're using the event
log on Windows etw tracing then you will
want to take these hooks and add the
integration points yourself to make sure
that all your events are in the same
place so all the transparency you
already have in the operating system
these will let you add piping into that
so you also have insight into Python
mixed in with everything else that
amount of information is huge
significant you need to determine what
looks good what looks bad but by adding
this in the ability to attack is to hide
inside a piping process is gone and that
stream of events from the operating
system now includes the events from
Python and you can see into them so what
events are these what do we go and this
list is incomplete because
it's trivially easy to add more hooks
and the proposal isn't yet merged into
Python so we still have the flexibility
to add more things but here's a brief
grouping there are things that all code
does that get locked every single import
gets notified gets wanted you can see
every single module that gets imported
you can see every bit of code that gets
compiled every socket created every
access to network by URL Lib which is
the lowest-level so basically everything
you go through that at some point all
what you can see all of those there are
things that most code never does these
are also very interesting because your
code might do this but you'll know about
it but if you see them happening you
probably want to thank closer look exact
eval gonna show up from time to time ID
is you're interested in Y ID is a big
deal and come chat to me afterwards and
I'll introduce you to someone who
exploited that to make triples mutable
array in C types struct which lets you
redefine how plain on memory looks and
interpreted into Python it's rare but
very useful for certain attacks there's
a whole range of functions in the sis
module that let you change the state of
things
adding traces adding debuggers adding
profiling you're very rarely going to do
it you want to know if someone does
because you don't know what they're
doing with it and also monkey patching
if you've ever wanted to see every bit
of monkey patching that happens in your
code there is a hook here that will let
you order that and see every time
someone changes an attribute on a class
and finally there's events that no one
should ever do for example if you've set
up an ordered hook so that you have some
code to be called whenever an event
happens if someone else does that they
probably shouldn't be doing that because
you did that so you get to hear about it
prototype new function type this is
directly in satiating a code object
which again very useful if you want to
exploit Python very very very rare in
genuinely good code
if it gets through a code review then
you've got the hard discussion happen
code review our sister get frame or
current frames again oh I'll take a
stand on sister I'll get Frank don't do
that but again people do and unpick load
up fine class if you've ever been told
don't use pickle because it's not safe
it's because of this function you will
now get called by a pet five five one
ordered hook so you can do whatever you
want you can raise a big red flag well
you can just crash so the API for this
this to api's the C API and a Python API
again if you care enough to be doing
this then I'm going to assume that you
care enough to compile a new entry point
if this is merged into Python you don't
have to recompile the whole thing but
the entry point which is typically one
line of code can have a second line of
code that sets up an order then when you
initialize Python every single thing
that it does is going to go to your C
function it's going to go to the C
function first it's the most secure way
of doing this it's not possible to
remove from within five that's this the
API is very straightforward you get the
name of the events coming in and you get
a tuple of values the schema for those
is matched to the event name those are
all defined in that and those will not
change over time so if you receive the
import event we know what the arguments
are you can pause them you can do other
issues with them they aren't going to
change there's also a Python API for
this so that if you want to quickly
write a hook or something that you don't
mind not starting until the process is
running and potentially already
compromised then you can add it later on
and this is handy for testing it's handy
for debugging and it's handy if you want
if you simply want to do things like
detect all monkey-patching that happens
while you're running your tests then
it's perfectly fine to use these hooks
from the python api during something
like running tests and a neat thing here
is you don't have to succeed these if
you raise an exception from any of these
books it's going to bubble out and it's
probably going to bring the process down
so if there are things that
you know about that should never happen
you can crash essentially in these hooks
as an example one of the exploits that
I've seen generates an invalid code
object that is then used to modify
values that it shouldn't have access to
in the hook for creating a new code
object I added a few lines of code to
validate the code object just scan the
byte code it was passing it and if it's
invalid it raises an exception and now
that exploit it's broken because you
can't create an a callable code object
from from compromised code so it's very
handy for this again the main point of
these enhancements is transparency not
protection getting a log message it's
far more important than stopping the
process is an example of this with a few
bits in it from that bit of code earlier
we saw run the log that it was going
through a bitly URL to get to its
payload we don't use bitly in our app we
know that we never none of our urls use
bitly no user provided data should ever
be doing that so we're happy to say if
someone is trying to go through a bitly
URL we'll just block will just cancel it
so here are the pieces of this this hook
gets called with the event name every
time we create the request object it's
going to be passed in some arguments
first of these is the URL so we can look
for some pattern in this you can use a
red X instead you could use any sort of
matching you like here we're going to
display a message we're going to log and
detect and report that this is going on
and for good measure here we're actually
just going to abort it and so someone
who's thinks they're constructing a
request object or they calling URL open
it's going to see an error they don't
expect chances are it's going to bring
down the whole processor you could catch
this and do something different and if
you really want to prevent that then you
do something like post on exit that is
uncatchable and finally we're just gonna
use a Python API to add this hook which
does mean that if someone has something
run before we had this hook then it's
going to get through and we're not going
to know about it
depending on your purposes that may not
be a big deal so with this hook if I
take this code and run it again we get
different output you'll see that we get
the warning first and then we bring down
the whole process with an error message
rather than letting it even occur to sum
up where this proposal is that as I say
it's a proposal at five five one it's
published online you can look it up and
find it for all the details but it's not
in C piping yeah still working through
the proposal process to get it in there
is a working implementation I have
published that it's on my github linked
below from the tiny URL either against -
37 or alpha 2 which is the latest
version 3 7 and also against Python 36 3
works on Windows Mac Linux it's
completely cross-platform because it
doesn't really do anything yet until you
add your half the implementation to
integrate into your auditing system my
contact is there if you want to get in
touch with me or you can get in touch
with me on Twitter happy to take any
questions about this and would certainly
love to hear your feedback and if your
organization or company is interested in
making use of it Thank You performance
penalty so in the benchmarks that I have
run and I have run benchmarks if you
don't have any order folks at all
there is no performance penalty and I
say that base I know you know with a
roomful of data people no one's gonna
believe that
but the benchmarks the benchmark suite
has been fairly well validated at this
point some benchmarks came in faster son
came in slower there's no good reason
for them to be faster but none of them
had a statistically significant
difference everywhere there is a fork is
Purdy a slow operation so if you're
downloading something off the network
then checking to see whether you should
call an auditing book it's very cheap
compared to waiting for the internet to
get back and that's the case for
essentially all of these calls also
Eydie is the only slow life again
shouldn't really be using ID and to be
clear hash does not go through the ID
function so that's not going to affect
hashing or a dictionary lookups or
anything like that so performance wise
not like no impact when you're not using
it if you are using it then you get to
control them you get to decide what the
performance impact will be based on how
well you optimize your audit hook if you
write it in C and you have efficient
string comparisons for the event name
which comes in as a plain old string it
can be as fast as you like it to be and
most auditing or logging platforms
especially for security or os level
stuff are already highly optimized so
you're unlikely definitely a huge impact
but it depends on how much you're
logging in what you're doing with them
but it is entirely up to you
no that's that's certainly the case and
the lump a has plenty of Python level
places where you could add books there
is an API that I didn't mention to
actually ordered something so if you
want to add an auditing event to say a
third party library if this is accepted
than as of a certain version there would
be a sista audit function that is always
there it's not conditional you don't
have to check for it it's very cheap to
call if there's no hook enabled but it
is there it is callable and that can let
you add new auditing events to other
libraries if you want to hear from say
numb PI or PI win32 what it's doing in
the sea level equivalent but as you say
there are dangerous libraries c-types is
in the standard library someone's using
that they could be doing all sorts of
stuff and it's very interesting to know
what that is even if your own code is
using it and PI 132 is much the same for
Windows I would strongly recommend
trying to avoid that if possible if only
because if you start reading books that
people have written about you know
hacking widows using Python h1 is
essentially install PI win32 and then
the rest of the book assumes you have PI
132 so if you can find a way either by
figuring out what api's you need to call
and setting up with your own siphon
module or even like a pre-compiled
terrify module to call those so you
don't have to use dynamic lookups on the
machine then that's going to be a big
advantage and avoiding the well-known
big modules like pi win32 I'm not saying
avoid numpy and dump layer certainly had
buffer overflow issues and if you find
those then you need to record and patch
them but the advantage of the one brings
in that case is we still have to do
something with the buffer oh and if
that involves running more Python code
this proposal will help you see that and
give you enough information to trace
back and find that it was a buffer
overflow and numpy that was exploited to
get you that you may not have that
amount of information without the
transparency that comes through having
us invited yes
so in the case where you have a library
that you've written in C if you've
written it yourself then you obviously
have the freedom to add your own what it
in books directly if it's like an
in-house proprietary library there is as
I said there's a C API for adding hooks
that becomes available with the patch or
if this gets most into Python it will be
there and let you have formal books add
it to your own code or alternatively if
you hook at the outside again the value
here is determining if someone is trying
to exploit fight them on your machine or
trying to hide their activity and if
your library is not helpful for that
then it's likely not going to be helpful
to an attacker and logging it may just
be adding notes and logs without adding
anything useful it's really an
evaluation that you have to make
yourself based on the purpose and the
use of the library yes
yeah so the question is is there any way
to avoid event names colliding no and
that may be something that's worth
adding into the pepper as a
recommendation for third parties I I
would say prefix your event names with
your package name and then at the very
least people can't have two colliding
packages and so at the same time because
if you have numpy dot events because
you've got none type someone else you
might have those events but again before
before you even when you deploy this
what are the first things you need to do
is look at the events and see that
you're getting useful information and
that should show you very quickly we
have colliding names for events because
you're going to see all sorts of issues
there's no other questions thank you
very much I'll be around today